it's friday december 5th and you're
watching the gamespot news top 5. i'm
chris waters here to host you through a
quick rundown of the week's stories and
get you on your way because the weekend
is here almost and you've probably got a
lot of games to play just like me or
maybe like other things that people do
on the weekends go go to place eat
eat a thing what what do people do even
anymore
maybe the news will tell us
well one thing people did last week was
decide to buy xbox ones over playstation
4's during america's national shopping
orgy black friday
retail analytics firm info scout
gathered data from 180 000 participants
who sent in pictures of their receipts
with their phones from target walmart
best buy radio shack gamestop and others
53 of respondents purchased an xbox one
while 31 picked up a ps4 compared to
last year current gen console sales went
up last gen console sales went down and
the wii u held steady at six percent
keep on trucking little fella this week
marked the 20th anniversary of the
playstation and to commemorate the event
sony released console collector catnip
in the form of a special edition ps4 the
custom console has the grayish ps1 look
to it and a number emblazoned on it to
tell you which one of the 12 300 copies
you have there are a bunch of other neat
throwback design touches that you can
get a closer look at in gamespot's
unboxing video and then consider if you
want to place a pre-order for 500
euro when they go on sale saturday
morning at 10 a.m pacific less than a
month after two assassin's creed games
launched guess what there's another
assassin's creed game assassin's creed
all day every day forever this is your
life now
leaked in a report by kotaku the next
mainline entry in the series assassin's
creed victory is set in the victorian
era in london and see what they did
there yeah and it's currently slated as
the only assassin's creed game to
release next fall development on the
current gen only title is headed by
ubisoft's quebec studio as opposed to
the usual montreal the game will feature
a grappling hook for swinging about as
well as vehicular combat which appears
to be just punching dudes while carriage
surfing ubisoft isn't exactly happy
about the leak and said in a statement
that they are still focusing their
energies on quote enhancing the
experience of assassin's creed unity aka
unbreaking it
street fighter 5 is coming to the pc and
playstation 4.
did i forget a platform there
nope
the teaser trailer presumably meant to
be released during the playstation
experience this weekend has already been
pulled down and little is known about
the project except yeah that exclusivity
might be timed might not be but an xbox
one release was conspicuously absent
from the announcement pc and ps4 only
and finally australian targets and
kmarts have decided this week to pull
grand theft auto 5 from sale after
examining the content and finding it
objectionable target statements
specifically cited depictions of
violence against women as the reason
while k-mart's statement was more
general but they're both owned by the
same company an australian corporation
called west farmers so it's probably not
a coincidence two retailers removing the
game from sale may be cause for concern
but remember it wasn't long ago the
australian classification board a
government body actually censored or
banned the sale of some games this
target kmart thing doesn't really
compare and since the introduction of a
new r18 plus classification in 2013
government censorship of games has been
drastically reduced if you live in
australia please chime in in the
comments with your thoughts and offer a
bit more context than this humble host
can offer
that's it for the news so far this week
but coming up tonight it's the game
awards in las vegas a lot of new game
announcements and trailers are expected
to be shown and gamespot will be
streaming the whole thing live so come
on back at 6pm pacific to check it out
and if you miss it live we'll be posting
all the good bits on the site shortly
after as well as all the stuff from the
playstation experience all weekend long
on gamespot.com news bye-bye